shit's too serious it's like what come
yeah you got any come related stuff um I
was gonna we've talked about this before
but public masturbation okay not like
public but not in front of people but we
talked about this ones I think I jerked
off in a gas station bathroom remember
the story mm-hmm why none no no was it a
big story no I mean the we're on like a
road trip and I was just so I was like
14 I was horny as [ __ ] okay yeah and
then we went to this gas station and
[ __ ] in the car and stuff like that yeah
just I couldn't I was going crazy I just
my parents actually put me in a car seat
still because I just wouldn't relax
[ __ ] knock it off back there yes I'm
not gonna stop humping stopping no just
some like blanket stuffed animals
wherever you can get it's the [ __ ]
car seat in the bags go knocking the
coffee's out a cup holders
Travis you knock it off back there I'm
not gonna mom that's your son back there
I'm gonna pull over in New York you're
gonna you're gonna deal with him as I'm
not doing it anymore
he got that from you you know he did I'm
not that horny I've been to church every
Sunday since I was 14 yeah I've never
had this problem but you don't even
start with me pull up to the gas station
open the [ __ ] sliding door in the van
he's just like a [ __ ] heretic in
there it's going crazy chairs going nuts
they just [ __ ] unclip him and let him
loose just runs into the gas stations
knocks over a thing at chips and just
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of the chips gas
station attendant calls the police he's
here still horny boy [ __ ] a bag of
[ __ ] takis so that was you yeah okay
now we were at this we're driving to
Vegas and we stopped at this gas station
and I mean God forbid my parents
ever hear this episode they're gonna be
like you know they knew they know they
always know no it's always now no no
there's no way sir so so this you
thought you thought you were being
subtle
not really you were in the in the
bathroom
I really hope my dad doesn't come in
here and realize that I'm jerking oh I'm
jerking off in the bathroom yeah this
particular bathroom in so this gas
station was huge
and I was like I was like blown away
like oh [ __ ] they had two bathrooms and
one of them was kind of like tucked away
and I walk into this bathroom and this
is the most disgusting thing possible
the floor was carpet oh yeah yeah yeah
it was like a pink carpet and it looked
like used to be white yeah well isn't
completely full of bacteria in blood
yeah yeah when there's blood all over it
I just like the just the straight-up
elephant ring in the bathtub pink no no
and it was like this soft pink and I
just set the mood for me I went right to
that handicap stall and I waited like a
minute or two and no one came in and I
was like it's going down this is where
I'm gonna do it let it rest is where I
become a man yeah right here yeah I let
her rip and not no one I had that thing
all to myself for the entire that's when
you become a man actually when you jerk
off in a public restroom yeah yeah truly
that's when you become a man now I know
literally everyone is probably with the
jaw open like why would you retell this
story we forgot this story why the [ __ ]
would you admit to doing this yeah yeah
me too a little bit yeah um it's
disgusting now that I look back at it
but that was a teenager in me mm-hmm
just couldn't hold it in
why are you telling this story though
because when you said on the the [ __ ]
like when I thought you said oh I used
to jerk off in the Border's bathroom
this goes back to that yeah
at first I was gonna judge you and then
I was like now I'm a hypocrite cuz I did
that one time
yeah I remembered them the moment I
completed the mission I was like what
the [ __ ] have I just done like I just
did a felony I was like oh my god go
back in the car help I can't tell Oh
bright like how would they be able to
tell no but I like that I like [ __ ]
for a second after I remember thinking
oh [ __ ] is there a camera in here but
then I laughed and a 14-year old me was
like if there was a camera in here
spying on a little boy doing anything in
here that'd be [ __ ] illegal [ __ ] yeah
so I washed my hands like profusely went
back to the car and was just started
like go back that's when you go back and
sit down and trying to play it off you
know watching your little movie on your
little DVD player or whatever and their
dad it's like smells like somebody
jerked off in here
smell like jerking off it's funny
because you wouldn't think that has a
smell but that has a smell post jitters
no jerking off has a smell um yeah it
does
post jerking off whatever you you know
just just in general oh yeah there's a
smell yeah her cough has a smell I mean
there's definitely that me there's
everything there's so many the smell of
like your balls shame shame yeah this I
mean this one it all mixed together then
I smell of jerky no that should be a
cologne that we sell shame and it smells
like post masturbation yeah she imagines
like one of those [ __ ] commercials
with goddamn a Johnny Depp yeah [ __ ]
will cast them was was a bad one was a
bad okay I'll leave it alone okay what a
bad joke I was gonna I was gonna say
yeah we're gonna cast a certain person
who okay he's not that bad what Louie CK
[Laughter]
is his looking at the floor the dog his
bald head shame
oh this is this voiceover you can feel
it it's all around you all the time it's
shame then he just looks the camera and
then it shamed by Dior and that would
sell probably think yeah just spraying
that on you it's a front that you get
that you jerk off the exactly don't jerk
off but you want people to think you
jerk off and because that's pretty
flexing the that you jerk off is cool
you think even if you don't you know
yeah so yeah I cranked off every now and
then I'll spank I'll spank one I spank
off at the gas station some middle
school as [ __ ] bragging about your your
jerky exacting habits
[Music]